joining me here in studio were sitting
right between Chris Brockman and I is
none other than my my good friend and
colleague from many drafts on the NFL
Network he is Charles Davis how many
drafts is is on the NFL net for you
I believe it's 12 or 13 a.m. yeah but
but I never forget my first one and this
would be quick but my first one if I'm
not mistaken and you know time does it i
sat up in the rafter seats everybody
musical uh-huh by myself and the idea
was that I might get some hits one hit
and you remember how it was in the old
days day one there's a draft you never
got to speak was we do three rounds then
oh no we did all when we when we showed
up City we we would do I know I did all
the way through to mr. irrelevant right
so there's a two days a two day or but
I'm saying the first day was rounds one
with one right three yes and so I sat up
there four rounds one through three and
I remember being up there and I don't
know if it's the same draft or not
because the time I apologize but that
unfortunately for my friend Brady Quinn
that was the Ted control and that was
the biggest explosion of noise outside
of a Jets or Giants pick remember
because we're always anticipating those
at Radio City yeah and when they
announce Ted Ginn I remember being up in
I feel like I was up in those those
raptor seats and place went I mean a
roof came off on that when people went
crazy and those who realized I was their
friend if they'll Network what just
happened I was like I'm with you I don't
know what just happened I know and that
was the draft for me where I realized
for the first time that Roger Goodell
being commissioner meant all figurative
bets were off on how things were being
run entirely in the NFL just because
they had been done a certain way for as
long as they've been doing them for the
draft for the combine for the Hall of
Fame for anything
everything was now on the tables are
near since Bert Bell because because
that was the draft when Brady Quinn was
dropping and he got him he went to he
would see the shots on the screen of all
of Quinn just in the Aaron Rodgers spot
and the in the Thurman Thomas spot you
know
Knakal room could just go on through the
history of the television the televised
draft of prospects who would just sit
there stewing in their own sweat waiting
for them to get the phone call and he
was sick and tired of watching Brady
Quinn do that so he went and got Brady
Quinn out of the regular green and put
him in his personal Commissioner
greenroom where there are no cameras no
cameras and that was a really cool move
and that was when it word came down to
all the television partners as well no
more shots of the prospects waiting for
the phone calls past I guess fifth pick
yeah something like that and now we
don't show many more to because them on
the phone tips off they're about to be
getting drafted and I love the fact that
we got to that there are people love the
intrigue people love the mystery and
people at home are spending their time
vetting each other on who the pick is
right and they wanted they want to
debate it out so I love the fact that
the pick is organic for everyone and in
the evolution of the draft you know it
just every year with just seeing the way
that the draft Hall set up here
Vegas is just gonna be king Saints going
from nashvegas this year to Vegas actual
next year is gonna be an ounce is that
four right think it's in Vegas I think
it's better yeah so you know I'm hearing
that they're turning Fremont Street into
the into the Wow
so that's the idea that's what I'm
hearing
Wow so anyway long story short though is
that it just shows you again it is a
television show they could do this draft
on an encrypted website like a fantasy
football draft and be done with it
technically within a few hours but
instead it's a television show and it's
an event it's an event that travels the
people invade in in Nashville here are
so fired up you're wearing your
Tennessee Hat you're a Tennessee vol you
know what of Sportback state right
exactly we'll get to that in a second
reason why I bring all this up is is
that proof that it's this is an event
and it is a television show is the fact
that if you and I are called off our
sets due to lightning tomorrow night yes
drafts they'll come when the show goes
on I mean there's still cuz there's no
way we were just joking off air could
you imagine mike Mayock first pick as a
general manager
they stopped the clock because there's
lightning in the draft hall and somebody
looks Mike and you say I'm hold off in
your back hold off in your pick there
could be other teams that are trying to
maneuver right now no pick to mess with
your later picks nothing but you can't
make your pick right now hold on could
you imagine there's lightning in
Tennessee
could you fortunately for the
commissioner's office that would be a
phone call because huh
cuz mike is in Oakland and not someone
having to walk in and tell Mike and John
right that that's going down that way
and we were just laughing right it means
okay the Commissioner goes up and says
Lightning TV
everyone's having to leave what have you
yeah we're suspending the draft the
Raiders have 6 minutes and 38 seconds on
the clock right it'd be like it'd be
like we used to spending playing golf
and the next day you got a remark your
ball the ball was here when we left it
or pick your sport right baseball
yes runners were on 2nd and 3rd there's
a 2 stone 1 & 2 count it's right back in
the bucket ARP out back back in the box
and off you go
we're not going to do it just want to do
they are they gonna have like a setup
like they have to come up with a setup
to continue announcing the picks they
have to look because the the the
broadcast can emanate from any anywhere
right so we're covering it world wide
lead role covered from from Los Angeles
and from Bristol Connecticut
respectively but somebody from the NFL
has got to still make the picks and I'm
just wondering like could we get like
Gil Brandt in his in his Barcalounger
like sitting there in his living room
via like Instagram live as he's being
measured for his Hall of Fame jacket
right or hold on or we tell Mayock this
is the best Hall you know tell me och
make your pick they're not going to
announce it from the stage in Nashville
because there's a weather delay there's
an orangutan Gazoo we had well I I went
into the truck yesterday after as you
watch me afternoon to watch me sweating
well no and into the truck we I went
into the truck after our dress rehearsal
yes
today to look at all the tapes there is
and I instagrammed about a great 38
second montage tape abraca
of the orangutan and how pissed Mayock
was during our dress I absolutely lost
it in that segment I mean you you you
had you had to try and brace me up
during that time close because I was
laughing so hard you remember I laughed
so hard that I needed the John Thompson
towel
I needed to coach Thompson towel and
people think I was laughing because of
the orangutan I was laughing because
Mike was so beyond tick tock
legitimately pissed like a sister and at
one point Mike did say if I see that
chimp one more time I'm walking on and
then say what you said basically say not
to be and do you remember I was laughing
so hard and the Mike was so mad he was
furious and I couldn't help it I just
kept laughing because I knew where he
was coming from and people have to
understand because Richard rich can
cosign on this when I'm guaranteeing
Mike's heart is in the right place on
all of these because he wants the kids
to get their mom ooh yes and he doesn't
like it when we take away from that so
that is pure all right that's someone
who cares I'm with him but that moment
was so nutty I know that I absolutely
lost it and then I think I don't know if
it's on the tape I doubt it is this
chosen I was I broke down the playing
attributes of rocky yeah I'm up on the
board like her own little graphic for
rock I play at will I think in the three
four I said could you imagine him
shedding with those with those of course
and shedding a blocker I said he would
be the best run chase linebacker and I
looked at in the corner of my eye of
mice looking at me like I oughta just
because he because he was disappointed
in you yeah he was because I missed that
I had lost that part and that was the
same draft that was so much fun because
now I do
we have rocky the orangutan bruno
sammartino and that's the pic for
Pittsburgh and I rolled into a
professional wrestling riff and I
thought he was gonna come over there and
choke me out it was outstanding that's
like oh yeah you remember and he trained
Larry's abisco and then Larry turned on
him and I wonder if they ever repaired
that rift and people are looking at me
where do we go that's again that's day
three of the draft when we get a little
bit loose and uh charles davis here on
the Rich Eisen show what what do you
what are you hearing about top of the
draft right now it's amazing how much
boy it just keeps going well I don't
know how much of this is sand being
thrown in our faces and that it really
is gonna be calamari at the top or or
because it just doesn't make sense to me
that we're too far down the road that
the Godfather deal for Cuyler Murray
from another team that they would get
because they have put on the face that
we're gonna take him if you don't come
up on get him like that moment I would
think we'll have passed if you remember
if you like it had the Rams gay traded
out in the RG three spot weeks before
yes the eagles moved up into the wench
spot twice weeks before right there yeah
they had to make a move to get the RAM
the Rams jumped up ahead of time right
to go from fifteen to one to get the
Titans so that hasn't happened so the
point is is like are you gonna take him
or not because you got Josh Rosen that
put his his fractured sensibilities back
together again and I'm sure time might
heal all that but we're reading stories
that Aaron Rodgers still couldn't
forgive Mike McCarthy for giving the
checkmark to Alex Smith's pick when he
was with the 49ers so but that's make of
all this and you know that last part is
not surprising because that's what all
the great athletes do right so there's a
chip to be played they'll carry it right
to the grave with them so rosin is is
hanging in the balance
and so what do you what do you think of
this I still believe Murray goes one I
think that it's actually been good for
not just us but for the draft itself
that there is some doubt at this point
short with the dye great pick you and I
both know that
when Charlie Castley our colleague
signed Mario Williams first yes it hurt
that draft we we talked about that from
from a viewer from a Stamper because now
1 & 2 were done because we knew New
Orleans now was taking so I agreed helps
the broad it helps the broadcast to have
some of that but I still think
ultimately they get to the podium and
announced Conor Murray at 1:00 and then
the draft truly begins at that point
because who does San Francisco take it
to is there any movement there it should
be beau so Ryan I would think it'd be
bosun because I just think that he can
play the defensive end opposite Dee Ford
and then when we get into those nickel
and sub-packages which we're playing
whatever that percentage is 75 80
percent of the time whatever it is he
just slides inside next to DeForest
Buckner hmm who had a breakout year last
year D Ford coming off of an edge wow I
really like that I really like the looks
of that and I think he's the most
technically proficient pass rusher in
this draft I mean watching his hand
placement what he does mm-hmm I mean
there's his one piece of tape for me
against I think as Oregon State he
pretty much took the poor tackle from
Oregon State grabbed his one arm and
spun him like a battling top and then
continued on and hit the quarterback
upside the head he's that type of a
player to me and I know the volume and
body of work isn't there as much because
of injury but we're doing that with kids
who are just getting one year of playing
time as a starter and coming up to the
NFL now so we just have to evaluate
faster Charles Davis here in the Rich
Eisen show and then when we did our our
I guess our mock draft which is our
dress rehearsal yes and the picks that
come out are like kind of a consensus of
everybody all our analysts right and
they put it all together so Chris when
we were doing our mock rehearsal
yesterday or a real rehearsal of our
mock draft who went first
it went Murray it went Bosa okay and
then and then out spat the Jets with
Edie Oliver it alright I'll tell you as
a jitter yes yeah because that was a yes
for real
yeah because to me you know if he's not
Aaron Donald he's still gonna be a damn
fine pass rusher take Aaron Donald life
and and somebody who's right there in
the middle who can stop the run
the weight of the quarterback that yeah
to me his upside and and a line that I
used by the way on during the rehearsal
that Coach Shaw who is on our show
tomorrow loved and I might actually use
on the air is that they should tell
Oliver he doesn't get a Jets coat
because Tom Brady's stole it and say
that tune build what nature's game go
get 12 he took your jacket because you
do cuz you know if you're not playing
you can't have a jacket story that's
what I mean you say Brady took your
jacket
that's number 12 go get it and besides
if you tell him look if you say that
he's half the player Aaron Donald this
right that's ten and a half sacks right
cuz Aaron by the way this is your movie
to ten and a half sacks mickey rourke
refrigerator took me a while after that
to enjoy food again but do you think
that out of all the choices after Bosa
everything's up and where everything's
up right that's what I'm saying
what would at would have Oliver be your
choice Oliver or Quinn and Williams I
think it's got to be their flavor on the
whole thing and the way I look at it
rich is very simply this Oliver has a
better body of work overall because of
three years at Houston people want to
talk about last year and shutting it
down and is okay that's fine in once
even first two years right okay clown he
went through that at South Carolina
Oliver gave him more lashes I think
clowny did his last year South Carolina
and then the flipside is Quintin
Williams is a one-year guy but we have
to keep remembering to quantify what
that means he's a one-year guy at
Alabama so who was there prior to why
didn't he get on the field that's right
Don Payne is there Jonathan Allen was
there oh they were first-round picks so
he played he was in the rotation but he
wasn't that key guy and I just thought
he took it and ran with it in his one
year there and there's no reason for him
to go back this close time for him to
come out so either one there four is
what gets interesting with Mike and and
John because we keep hearing the
surprise pick coming out and the scouts
got sent home I don't know that
necessarily that a surprise pick means
quarterback didn't we can run into that
last year with New Orleans yeah
I was all in thinking New Orleans had
come up to get more right we all thought
I said it on television
listen it made sense it wasn't it wasn't
just something you plucked out of the
air right and then they gave us Marcus
Davenport whoa that was a whole
different deal so I don't think it's
necessarily that into one thing to keep
in mind tres John's history as a head
coach and ask yourself what rookie
quarterbacks are yelling quarterback to
John like working with none of them
that's why I keep coming back to okay no
no you're gonna say you're gonna tell
them now okay this is it now maybe this
is different cuz it's only a second year
back in Oakland and maybe he thinks I
can reboot with a new guy and go from
there
I just I'm not I'm not convinced that
that would be the move therefore but I
will tell you this rich if it's a
surprise and I know edge rusher and
interior rush or any kind of rusher is
big for them linebackers where I keep
coming back to a guy to set the defense
start over I know Brandon Marshall is
there I know the Vaughn tez is there and
I figure van tez will play about half
the season if he's you know suspension
if they're so whatever
white from Devon white from LSU or Devon
Bush from Michigan
well here's a few things that would be
that would be a surprise because I know
you got to go and we have to hit break -
so lemons just finishes up full circle
in two minutes if that all happens yep
me and I'll say this again Mayock you
said he got pissed about the orangutan
making picks because he wants to give
the kids there that he had the same
respect for scouts he certainly did
always on air off air mentioning Scouts
name has nothing but respect for scouts
I think he sent them home because
they're tightening the rotation up there
they are and their draft board might
show that they do like players that if
Derek Carr heard about it then we got a
whole nother call and how bright of a
problem would it be if they'd actually
don't take those quarterbacks they need
to just tighten the rotation that he's
heard what he's heard from the scouts he
it's his time with Gruden and whoever
else they have they're not and they're
not his right so send him home I didn't
take that in any other way other than
just him time to tighten the rotation
his coaches do in the playoffs ask
around the league is tightened
everywhere and if he goes mike Mayock
with his fur and with his first pick
somebody like you just mentioned it the
linebacker spot I mentioned it on the
show yesterday I told the NFL Network to
pull the sound if you will they're
working on it last year when we're on
the clock with the Browns on our
broadcast Mayock went on like a 40
second soliloquy about how a general
manager like John Dorsey it's his first
pick as general manager as a first pick
as a general manager you've got to
choose someone that lets the building
know this is my idea of a prototypical
player for us on field off field
character wise everything and so
thinking about what you just said like
white or Devin Bush that makes total
sense from Mike to make that pick with
Gruden obviously it's Gruden's call like
an ultra cold right this is good that's
what it would be and then ultimately to
bring it full circle if Mike may ox
first pick is general manager is a
Michigan Wolverine oh I am gonna text
him I'm gonna blow his phone up do you
know if he does that rich fantastic if
he does that you know it would be like
be like dollar bill shorting the Elon
Musk flight that blew up remember that
one fantastic every one dollar bill was
sitting there look at you going aliens
right dollar bill send the rocket goes
up and poof thereby standing there in
shock and dollar bills like heck yeah
just hit the short baby and their lives
are lost all this time and money for
NASA gone and dollar bill is locked in
on how much they made take that full
circle to the chicken man when the
download trail was ready to go back
again man he's ready to go back in and
take care of business because that's
what I do for you acts that's what I do
for you that's the dollar bill that's
what I do for you acts and then they
flew home eating a bucket of chicken it
was an outstanding crate and then of
course I'll tell me I'll tell me I've
got him grabbing the bowling bag I mean
I actually tweet a dollar bill on the
bowling back at the dollar bill the
guy's dead and you took a bowling bag
you know what he tweeted back there what
anything he was gonna do with it anymore
outstanding dollar bill I've got to meet
Kelly a coin one of my things I could
actually make that happen you make that
happen
I want dollar bills you a football guy
yes I know is whose yeah
yeah well well dollar bill I'll do I'll
make that happen for you and then I can
tell I can't wait to tell Mayock you
said that he'll go billions that'll
break my salary Charles Davis at CFD 22
on Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app